I was asked about money and saving and
investing and what the most important
things are
um and uh let me say a few things first
the most important things are the basics
securing the basics you know
the bit that
place you live in the food you eat the
bed you sleep in the education of your
children
securing those types of things in
various ways you secure that in various
ways through your savings so think about
what are the basics that you need to
take care of and then the amount that
you need to take care of think think
about how many weeks months or years you
can go without having an income and that
means your security and when I did that
I found that I would build that savings
and then to diversify that to make that
a good investment so I think that start
with the basics what do you need for how
long and what do you have in
relationship to that that's most
fundamental then you can get into the
more esoteric stuff